Probably nothing is more critical to a
fair trial and reliable verdict on either
guilt or what penalty is imposed and
the fairness and the impartiality of the
judge presiding over a case.
We presume that a judge
is going to be fair,
that the judge is not going to be pro
prosecution and is not going to be a pro
defendant,
but it's going to call the,
uh,
legal issues that come up in the case.
What evidence to admit,
uh,
what evidence might be suppressed
because it was illegally seized or,
or Taegan how to instruct the jury that
all those decisions are going to be made
fairly and impartially.
Uh,
by the same token,
appellate judges are going to
review what happens at trial,
uh,
to decide if there's been
any error at the trial.
Uh,
that may require a reversal of
the conviction or the sentence.
Sometimes judges cannot
be fair and impartial.
And I,
a lot of times that's going to be obvious.
Uh,
the judge is related to one of the
lawyers and one of the parties,
uh,
or for some other reason the judge,
disqualifies himself or herself.
And so no issue is ever
presented in the case,
but there are going to be cases where
the impartiality of the judge is going to
be a closely contested.
And we're look at a few of those cases,
uh,
today and how courts
tried to sort them out.
Uh,
Supreme Court has said that the right
to a fair and impartial judge means that
the judge should have no temptation,
uh,
to forget the burden of proof
and not hold the balance.
Nice,
clear,
true,
uh,
between the prosecution and the defense.
Uh,
another way of putting that is a judge
may be disqualified if the judge's
impartiality might reasonably
be questioned if an
objective person knowing all
the facts involved,
uh,
had a doubt about the
judge's impartiality.
Then that judge had step aside and
another judge who presided over the case
where there's absolutely no question
that the judge can be fair and impartial.
One of the first cases where this came
up was burger versus United States in
this case,
in the burger versus United States.
Case involved just land justice Landis
later to be the commissioner of baseball.
Uh,
the affidavit claim,
the judge Landis had said,
if anybody has anything worse
to say about the Germans,
or we'll say anything worse than I have,
I liked to know what it
is so I can use it myself.
Uh,
he said that German Americans,
uh,
hearts are reeking with disloyalty
and that he knew a safe blower,
uh,
that he had given nine years,
and is now a soldier in France.
Uh,
and as between him and the defendant,
in another case,
uh,
he would prefer the same floor.
Uh,
this comment was made,
uh,
at a time when there was a great deal of,
hostile feeling towards
Germany during World War One.
A lot of hostile feeling towards German
and people of German descent and Victor
Burger,
the defendant in this particular case
was of German descent and also was a
socialist,
uh,
actually elected to Congress,
as a socialist.
Uh,
and he,
and,
uh,
the codefendants in this case,
we're saying that with
these kinds of attitudes,
judge land is,
could be fair and impartial in their case.
Uh,
and so that affidavit has filed.
Judge Landis denies it,
refuses to take himself off the case.
That goes to the Supreme Court,
which says,
first of all,
with regard to deciding the question,
the affidavit must be presented
under penalty of perjury.
In other words,
if the person who says that judge land
has said these things is lying about it,
he or she can be prosecuted for
perjury or if it's a lawyer,
they can be disbarred.
And the court said that's going to be
some protection against frivolous efforts
to get judges off the case.
And it must state facts,
not,
not rumors or gossip,
but facts that show bias
on the part of the judge.
Uh,
the judge when getting an affidavit
like this and a motion to disqualify the
judge simply looks at the affidavit.
And based upon what it says and
assuming the facts to be true,
the judge can't say,
I deny every single fact.
You said here the judge looks at it.
And if it appears that the
judge's impartiality might
reasonably be questioned,
it's their responsibility to judge,
step off the case,
recused themselves,
and let another judge,
uh,
take over the case.
Go no further.
Let the case be assigned to another judge.
That's what the Supreme Court held here.
Uh,
the prosecution or the defense may
know of bias on the part of a judge.
The judges also have a duty to disclose
any bias under the code of judicial
conduct,
which this is the Aba model code.
Now,
each state has its own version of this,
but there's not much difference.
A rule two point 11 says the judge would
disqualify himself or herself in any
proceedings in which the
judge's impartiality might
reasonably be questioned
what I've talked about.
So the judge has the first
responsibility to disqualify.
If the judge doesn't disqualify,
then the affidavit is file,
like the one in burger
versus United States.
The judge passes upon it.
The procedure may be very different,
uh,
in the state courts,
where there may be a
hearing by another judge,
there may be evidence taken,
there may be more development of the
record and some determination of the truth
or false,
a falsity of the allegations.
Uh,
but that's going to vary
from place to place,
uh,
among,
so what kind of disqualifying by biases
might adjudge have a personal opinion?
The judge has already
made up his or her mind.
Somebody supported the judge and
the campaign gave a lot of money.
Maybe it was the judge's campaign manager
and is now the lawyer for one side.
Uh,
one case involved a claim
of race discrimination and
the judge made the comment
outside of court,
well,
I know that person and that
person would never discriminate.
Well,
if the judge thinks that,
then the judge shouldn't
be sitting on that case.
And so another judge a w would decide
that case because that personal
relationship,
uh,
sometimes the judges have
knowledge of the facts,
uh,
such as being a witness or otherwise
knowing facts about the case which might
disqualify them.
Uh,
usually this has to be
extra judicial knowledge,
not knowledge the judge gained
in presiding over the case,
but knowledge the judge has from outside,
uh,
which is not properly considered.
Uh,
in the case,
uh,
misconduct during the trial,
very seldom is a case going to be
reversed because of a judge's misconduct
during the trial.
That is the judge berates one
lawyer humiliates the lawyer,
uh,
rules against the lawyer all the time.
The,
the remedy for that,
the courts say most of the
time is to appeal a conviction.
Uh,
but that may be a very unsatisfactory
remedy because of court of appeals may
very well say,
well,
what the judge did was improper and wrong,
but it wasn't harmful enough that
we're going to reverse the conviction.
So they're,
the defendant is with no relief
for what happened during the trial.
Um,
pecuniary interest a,
this is the probably the easiest one.
If a judge gets some
money out of the deal,
then obviously a judge can't
really be fair and impartial.
Some cases where the judges
would give part of the fine.
So a defendant comes before
the judge on a traffic matter,
say,
and if the judge imposes a,
a fine,
a percentage of the
fine goes to the judge.
A supreme court says you can't do that.
Uh,
because obviously the judge
has an incentive to find
people guilty and find them
since the judge is getting a cut of
whatever fines are being brought in.
Uh,
in the Ed and the life insurance,
a case,
it was a little bit different.
It was a case about,
uh,
insurance companies,
and one of the judges on the Alabama
Supreme Court got a pretty good settlement
in a case as a result
of that very decision.
And the Supreme Court said,
no,
that violates due process because the
judge had to direct the culinary benefit,
uh,
from the case.
That's not going to be the case
in criminal cases generally.
Um,
want to talk a little
bit about racial bias,
which is one other,
uh,
kind of bias that is
not raised a whole lot,
but it is often present in cases in the
morning to look at a couple of three
cases here where it was raised.
Uh,
it may be behavior off the bench,
such as the Louisiana judge who wore
blackface to a Halloween party a and said
he didn't mean to offend anyone.
Uh,
but he was sent to a,
uh,
some sort of sensitivity class
and was allowed to become a judge.
Uh,
the judge in North Carolina
who made a lot of racist jokes,
uh,
had to step down as chief judge,
but continued to stay on the bench as a
judge despite questions raised about the
judge's ability to be fair and
impartial in cases involving,
uh,
African American defendants
peak versus Florida,
uh,
was a case in which the Florida Supreme
Court after reversing the case for a era
that took place during
the sentencing phase,
the trial noted that the
judge in referring to the
defendant's family had used a
racial slur,
uh,
in describing them.
Uh,
and the court said,
just for future guidance,
uh,
we're telling judges that you should
avoid the appearance of impropriety.
Uh,
this judge,
had he been a sportscaster or had he
been some prominent public figure,
would almost certainly have lost his job.
But as a judge,
uh,
he is just simply told,
keep your racist thoughts to yourself,
uh,
and tomorrow and the next
day and every day from now.
And he can preside over cases despite
having shown this racial bias.
In this one particular case where
there are two cases out of Missouri,
both decided the same year,
uh,
state versus smalls and
state versus Kender,
uh,
both involve issues of race,
racial bias on the part of the judges.
In one case,
the Missouri Supreme Court fines,
racial bias.
And in the other case it doesn't.
Let's take a look at those cases and
whether there's a difference in what
happened.
Uh,
the first case,
uh,
was smalls here you had judge Karagan
who is presiding over the jury selection
process and the defense lawyer is making
an assertion that the prosecution is
striking jurors on the basis of race.
And so the defense lawyer wants
to make a record of every person.
The prosecutor struck whether
that person was black or white.
And when the defense lawyer as the
judge to note that one juror is African
American,
the judge says,
I don't know what it is to be black.
Uh,
I don't know what constitute black.
there's some dark complected
people and the jury,
but I don't know if that
makes them black or not.
I don't know.
Uh,
what constitutes is by years ago
they used to say one drop of blood,
uh,
constitutes black smallest raises
this on appeal saying the judges just
qualified because these remarks that
were made in responding to this,
she'll racial bias,
uh,
on the part a of the judge,
a judge white rights for the majority
of the only African American on the
Missouri Supreme Court.
Uh,
and frames the question this way,
whether there's an objective basis upon
which a reasonable person could have a
doubt about the racial impartiality of
the trial judge in this particular case,
uh,
points out that,
the context of this statement that was
made was in the midst of a race centered
issue.
In fact,
the issue here was,
was there discrimination
against black people?
Uh,
and also,
uh,
the descending opinion accuses
the majority being hypersensitive.
But justice white judge white says,
ah,
this is just simply acknowledging
that prejudice is very often subtle.
It,
it's not as blatant as it used to be.
A,
but when we see this kind of coded
language used and see the judge obviously
resistant to a supreme court decision,
which had said that there couldn't
be discrimination against blacks,
and he's basically saying,
I don't even know what black is.
I don't know how we can tell who's
black and who's white in this situation.
Given the context,
given what the judge said,
the one drop of blood,
all of that,
the judge is disqualified
from any further proceedings.
In this case,
a judge limbo,
descents,
uh,
he says the trial judge's insensitive,
but he's not racially biased.
This is what often is the response
to claims of racial bias that it's
insensitivity.
Uh,
and uh,
limbo says the judge was just having
difficulty figuring out who was black and
who was white,
uh,
in the jury pool.
Um,
the next case,
the Kender case,
uh,
Brian Kender that justice limbo.
We'll be writing a and we will see that
much of what the court said in smalls is
going to be a set aside or,
or,
or the law in this area
is going to be rewritten.
A just a short time later,
uh,
with judge,
limbo in the majority.
Here's what happened in kinder kinder's
about to go to trial and a death penalty
case.
Uh,
six days,
Brian kinders and African American,
six days before trial,
the trial judge,
Judge Blackbaud beside announces that
he is changing political parties.
He's running for reelection that year
and he says that he is switching from the
democratic to the Republican parties
because the Democratic Party places too
much emphasis on minorities
such as homosexuals,
people who don't want to work and people
whose skin is any color but white.
And he says it's time for us to place
much more emphasis on the hardworking
taxpayers in this country.
Uh,
Kender says,
wait a minute,
and I'm facing trial six days from now.
The judge is basically said that the
Democratic Party represents homosexuals.
People don't want to work and people
whose skin is any colored black,
uh,
and suggesting that he has
for the hardworking taxpayers.
Uh,
this suggests an appeal to race,
which shows the racial bias and
therefore he should be disqualified.
Again,
context is important
here because head this,
a press release been issued
it no significant time,
uh,
it might've been seen
as a bit distasteful,
but,
but not as relevant to a legal issue.
But here it's issue just six
days before a capital trial.
Well,
as I said,
ah,
now judge Limbaugh's writing,
uh,
for the majority and he says
recusal was not required.
One because we presume the judges act
with honesty and integrity and making
their decision.
Judge Black Wall had said at one point,
uh,
that everybody is absolutely entitled
to their constitutional rights,
whether they're yellow,
red,
white or Polka dot,
which may be suggested a
certain amount of sarcasm there.
Uh,
according to judge Limba,
uh,
the judge did in fact give a fair trial.
So he was true to his word.
He gave a fair trial.
Uh,
and in this distinction that the press
release that was issued was a political
act,
that it was not a judicial act but a
political act and therefore it didn't come
into play.
Uh,
and the limbo now wants to distinguish
the smallest case by saying the reason
the judge and smalls was disqualified
was because he wouldn't follow the law.
Because in,
in this race discrimination case,
he wouldn't recognize the race of a juror,
uh,
and wouldn't follow the law.
A judge,
judge white who wrote smalls
takes issue with that.
Uh,
in his dissent,
he calls the press release a
pernicious racial stereotype,
race baiting nonsense,
uh,
suggesting that minorities
are not hardworking people.
Uh,
and that you can't disregard this,
uh,
just simply because the judge
says that he can be fair.
Judges will often say they can be fair.
The question is whether a
reasonable person looking
at the facts would think the
judge did or did not harbor any bias.
Chris would kinders worried about is
that the judge running for reelection,
having now a changed political parties
may be tempted and remember that that
standard,
whether the temptation
is not to hold a balance,
nice,
true and clear between the
defendant in the state,
whether there's now a temptation to use
this capital trial and the rulings in
this capital trial in a way
that will help the judges,
uh,
political fortunes.
Um,
he also says the majority mischaracterizes
his opinion and smalls that it wasn't
about a willingness to follow the law.
It was that a judge be free from the
appearance of racial prejudice against a
defendant or any racial group.
You also suggest that what Judge Blackwell
did in issuing this pressure release
was perhaps more egregious than
what happened in smalls and smalls.
The judge has an outburst in
the middle of jury selection.
When the lawyer says,
uh,
I want you to recognize that this juror
is black and the judge goes off and
says,
I don't know what black
is and goes into that,
uh,
those words we looked at a moment ago.
Whereas here,
uh,
this is a press release,
a,
this is an appeal to the voters.
This is something that's put together,
that's proof read,
that's a refined,
uh,
and then announced at a press conference,
and is actually a stronger indication.
Justice White's suggests then,
um,
the,
the what happened and,
and smalls,
uh,
but he's all by himself,
just as white as all by himself
and dissent in this case.
So these cases are decided
by the Missouri Court,
uh,
and um,
do not see this kind of
issue come up very often,
uh,
but probably should be raised,
more often.
Uh,
this brings us to our next issue,
which is political pressures on judges.
Uh,
our political acts and
political considerations,
uh,
separate from judicial acts
and the federal courts.
The judges are appointed by the president,
United States and subject to
confirmation by the Senate.
Once they're confirmed there,
they have their jobs for life.
They may be ambitious and they may want
to move to a higher court or they may
want some other,
uh,
political advancement,
but at least they are secure
in the jobs they have not.
So in the state courts in the state
courts or judges run for election every
four,
six years.
Some states the judges are
up for retention election.
That is just a vote,
yes or no,
whether to keep that
judge in office or not,
or judges run head on.
And states like Alabama and Texas,
uh,
judges run under party labels,
Democrat,
Republican,
uh,
against each other.
Uh,
and as we will see where the full array
of campaign advertisements which are
growing and growing and growing,
as the amount of money funneled
into judicial campaigns increases,
uh,
with every election cycle.
Uh,
so,
uh,
before one election,
voters in Alabama saw this advertisement,
which involved a young lawyer
who's getting a call from
the chief justice of the
State Supreme Court.
Tom Is Chief Justice Warren.
Judge Warren's been well,
good morning to you,
sir.
You won't bond $500 for you campaign
from each member of the phone.
Well,
now you know,
judge,
we do have a case panning and your court,
it doesn't matter.
Yes sir.
I'll get the money up to you right away,
sir.
Well,
I'd imagine that it would be a little
disturbing to people to think of judges,
whether it be the chief judge or any other
judge dialing a lawyer who has a case
before that judge for
money for their campaign.
Uh,
but today it's quite frequent.
In fact,
today it's not unusual for
a camp candidate for a state
Supreme Court to have a
fundraiser,
uh,
sponsored by prominent lawyers who have
cases before that judge for the judge to
come.
Sometimes the fundraisers
are held at law firms,
uh,
or maybe held,
somewhere else,
but the judge may calm and shake
hands and thank people for making the
contribution.
So there's no secret about
who is supporting that.
These committees of people,
usually prominent lawyers from all
different walks of life who are supporting
the judge.
Uh,
so the question comes when you,
when you have that kind
of financial support,
that kind of public support for the judge,
can a judge still be fair and impartial?
Uh,
and judges are generally going to face
far greater attacks than what chief
justice Hornsby faced.
Uh,
it's not just going to be a matter of
whether they solicited cane being called
out for soliciting campaign funds.
Uh,
the generally,
uh,
it's going to be about decisions
the judges made in criminal cases.
Very often these cases are really,
are these elections are really a fight
between the business community that it's
interested on caps on punitive
damages and civil cases,
uh,
or,
or other civil matters.
And between the plaintiff's Bar,
uh,
which does none of that is the lawyers
representing people who are suing
insurance companies or
businesses or whoever,
and they're trying to win
as much money as they can.
But the campaigns aren't about that.
The campaigns are most often
about issues of criminal justice.
And A,
we're looking at one,
uh,
penny white,
voted off the Tennessee Supreme Court.
Uh,
this was a retention election in
which shortly before the election,
uh,
suddenly,
people started to get mail that said
that penny white had voted to free,
uh,
this man,
Odom who had committed this awful crime.
In fact,
the court had not freed him.
It had just simply reversed his death
since and sent the case back for a re
sentencing where he was
against sentence to death.
But judges had been voted off
the courts a number of times,
particularly for their votes
in death penalty cases.
Uh,
three in California in 1986 and since
then on the Texas Court of Criminal
Appeals,
uh,
the Mississippi Supreme
Court Justice White,
uh,
and of course locally
that has happened as well.
A trial judge in a local community,
maybe three or four counties,
uh,
has to know that if he or she makes a
controversial ruling or an unpopular
rolling,
uh,
in a death penalty case,
it could very well cost him the election,
uh,
when,
when they run for reelection,
that if they rule in favor of
a defendant in a capital case,
no matter how clear the law is,
that that ruling is required.
Uh,
they may be signing their own political
death warrant if they do that.
Uh,
2010 chief justice of Illinois was
on the ballot for retention election.
A yes or no election.
Uh,
business interests a raised about
$670,000 for the campaign against him.
Uh,
but the campaign wasn't about business
interest as as we'll see in a moment.
Uh,
Kale Brides,
a committee raised 2.8 million.
1.4 of that came from the Democratic
Party at about a 460,000 from the,
uh,
Illinois Federation of teachers.
Uh,
quite a bit of money spent on a retention
election and most of it went into 32nd
ads.
Uh,
there were many ads and
many ads about crime,
but here are some actors portraying,
uh,
inmates in prison.
And one of the ads that was run against,
uh,
chief justice Kilbride.
I was convicted of stabbing victims
with a kitchen knife or shooting my ex
girlfriend and murdering her sister in
front of our child of sexual assault on a
mom and her 10 year old daughter.
And I slashed her throat.
It's on appeal.
Justice Thomas Kilbride side with
us over law enforcement or victims.
Other judges overruled Kilbride
in our appeals were denied.
Kilbride chose criminals
rights over and over again.
We more than any other justice.
No.
On retention of Thomas Kilbride vote down,
bounce.
It's a top priority.
Kilbride had many ads run against him
saying that he put a criminals over.
Victims are criminals over other people.
Uh,
the next dad was running
against Louis Butler,
the old way African American
on the Wisconsin Supreme Court.
Uh,
and look for the racial
implications of this ad.
Again,
uh,
the sort of a theme that ran through the
campaign against Butler was that he was
loophole Louis,
that he always found a loophole
to get criminals off on
unbelievable shadowy special interest
supporting Louis Butler are attacking
judge Michael Gable woman.
It's not true.
Judge District Attorney Michael Gable
make has committed his life to loving up
criminals,
to keep families safe,
putting child molesters behind bars.
For over a hundred years,
Louis Butler worked to put criminals on
the street like Reuben Lee Mitchell who
raped an 11 year old girl
with learning disabilities.
Butler found a loophole.
Mitchell went on to molest another child.
Can Wisconsin families feel safe with
Louis Butler on the Supreme Court?
This was a very misleading ad.
Uh,
Butler did not rule on Mitchell's case
as a member of the Wisconsin Supreme
Court.
He had represented Mitchell when
he was a public defender long ago,
early in his career before he
became a member of the court.
Second,
Mitchell did not get off on a loophole.
He served his entire sentence,
uh,
in prison.
And also notice at the end of that add
the merger of the faces of Reuben Lee
Mitchell,
the criminal with Louis Butler,
both black men both wearing glasses.
And this sort of almost like butler,
uh,
is a personification or the
representation of Mitchell,
uh,
to the voters of Wisconsin.
A gay woman,
uh,
beat Butler in this election,
and now sits on the
Wisconsin Supreme Court.
Uh,
will these kinds of ads raise lots
of questions about how judges behave,
both what influence it has on their,
uh,
seeking office,
what they're willing to
promise to get office.
And there are two things that
we're concerned about here.
One,
how do we get the best judges?
Uh,
are we better off for the
nominating commission that
tries to just select people
on the UN on the basis of merit?
They're always going to be politics
involved and there will be there too.
Uh,
but that's a system that some states have.
or are we better off with a,
uh,
an election system in which anybody can
run for judge and we have a knockdown
drag out campaign.
It's pretty much decided on the basis of
32nd ads at least statewide campaigns.
Sorry.
Now that wouldn't be as true
for a local judicial election.
But the second question is how
once a person is on the bench,
however they got there,
how do we make it possible for the judge
to decide the case on the law to decide
the case based on the law,
without any fear that if the judge calls
it as the law requires that the judge
is going to remain an office and has the,
uh,
the,
the protection,
uh,
that an unpopular ruling,
will not be a basis for,
uh,
being voted out of office.
Judges are not like legislators,
presidents,
other people who are supposed to represent
the public will a responsibility of,
of judges to uphold the law
even when it's unpopular,
a free speech.
And even when somebody hasn't
very unpopular thing to say,
the judge's responsibility is to
say under the First Amendment,
the United States constitution,
you have a right to say these things
are to parade in this area or to publish
this newspaper,
whatever it may be.
And by the same token,
in criminal cases,
when there's a tremendous amount of the
and the prejudices of the moment coming
into the judicial process,
it's the judge's responsibility to hold
back those forces to grant the change of
venue,
uh,
maybe to another jurisdiction,
although that may,
that may make the judges constituents
unhappy because they wanted to decide that
case or to continue the case until a
later time after some of the passion has
died down,
a number of decisions that
judges are going to be made,
uh,
making,
that may or may not be
influenced by politics.
Well,
I'll end this series of ads
with one of the most upbeat ads,
uh,
that's running the last few years.
This was sue bell cob,
a running for chief justice
of the Alabama Supreme Court
Zoo.
Bill Cobb was raised in Evergreen,
Alabama and sue bill
cubs values her faith,
her family shine brighter every day.
She graduated at the top of her class and
with honors from law school and became
judge sue Belcamp,
a pioneer for women judges
and Alabama history.
She put thousands of criminals in jail.
Per House was fire bombed,
but judge sue bell carb
only grew stronger,
more determined.
She served 40 counties and today
judge Sue Bell Club decides life.
While all those years
outside the courtroom,
judge sue bell Cobb became
a state and national leader,
a reformer helping
children stay out of jail.
The southern woman kind and caring,
strong and determined.
Judge Sue Bell copic is
our chief justice should be
pretty good advertisement
for use in the Bible belt.
Uh,
also as I said,
one of the few positive
advertisements and that year,
uh,
on the entire Ballard in Alabama,
the only Democrat who got elected
to anything with Subo Cobb,
who got elected chief justice of Alabama,
she later a retired as chief justice,
but she did a win that election.
So at times,
uh,
a positive approach,
although there were plenty
of negative ads as well,
uh,
that ran in that election cycle.
Uh,
but,
uh,
that ad was seen as having played a big
role in her success as being elected to
the cork.
Whether or not that's what should be
deciding who sits on our courts or not is
the question I will leave for you to
think about the independence of the
judiciary.
The judges are independent
that they decide cases based
on the law and the facts
without any other political,
financial,
any other,
uh,
influence whatsoever.
Uh,
is one of the most important
issues in our society today,
uh,
is justice for sale.
Uh,
are good people discouraged from being
judges because they don't want to go
through these elections
with these negative ads.
They don't want to have the one
case that they decided in which,
and of course the court is always
going to reverse some case.
So if you go back through
a judge's whole record,
you're going to be able to find some case
where the judge set aside a conviction
who take that one case,
blow it all out of proportion,
and suggest that that case,
like what penny white to the Odom case
was everything that justice white stood
for,
uh,
over her long career,
as a both a trial,
a judge,
as an appellate judge,
uh,
in,
in Tennessee,
uh,
money in politics are at odds with
a fair and impartial judiciary.
But today,
money and politics play a
greater and greater role,
uh,
in who's elected to the bench
and who presides over cases.
And it has a big effect on the fairness
of trials and on the behavior of
appellate judges in deciding whether to
affirm or to set aside a death penalty
case or any other criminal case
because of a constitutional violation.